in meinem letzten video habe ich
süßigkeiten aus meiner kindheit
ausprobiert unter einem kommentar ist
eine diskussion zwischen vegetariern
veganern und fleisches sind entstanden
dieses perfekte beispiel dafür ist warum
vegetarier veganer und fleischesser sich
niemals eigentlich sein werden
viel spaß aber sie ist doch vegetarier
und ist süßigkeiten mit gelatine nur um
das kurz für alle klar zu stellen ich
bin ich fleisch esse ich nicht und die
meiste zeit ernähre ich mich mega
einfach weil ich so wenig tierische
produkte zu mir nehmen möchte wie ich
kann aber ich gehöre keinem klub an
dessen regel nicht befolgen muss und
deswegen als ich auch mal ein
gummibärchen oder probiere ein stück
torte das passiert aber so selten dass
ich das mit meinem gewissen vereinbaren
kann man seine beste einstellung
live-video wiegen
ja ich glaube du hast absolut gar nichts
verstand mal wenn er wegen dieses
schweinchen babe und bambis mutter
gestorben cool ich bin selbst vegetarier
und bewundere alle die sich vegan
ernähren wenn auch nicht feucht sein
würde es gern selbst probieren bin aber
noch zuletzt im kleiner also die meisten
gummibärchen sind mittlerweile aus
künstlicher gelantine also an organe
kein kleiner dachte ich mir auch zeigt
doch nur erneut wie kritisch die meisten
veganer vegetarier doch eigentlich sind
auch wenn sie sich selbst nicht als
solche 20 bezeichnen möchte ich esse
kein fleisch sondern nur etwas was das
fleisch produziert wird entweder ich
habe eine konsequente einstellung zu
etwas oder eben nicht aber dieses
infantile gelaber dass man veganer oder
vegetarier sei und dass ich so ein meere
und nur ab und zu fleisch oder tierische
produkte ist ist schlicht und ergreifend
eine form von charakterlosigkeit los
kann auch jeder selbst entscheiden was
er ist und selbst wenn sie die latina
ist ernährt sie sich noch
umweltbewusster als 99 prozent der
anderen menschen dieser welt wo ich esse
keine gelatine und du meinst man sowas
sagt schafft man es nicht ich habe noch
nie in meinem leben also 14 jahre ein
stück gelatine gegessen wollte laut über
geiles mal war und was man mit dem
fleisch in den akkus glaube ich kann nix
das war so jacke oder also etwa linz
katze aber danke finde ich gut bin auch
vegetarier außer wenn ich gerade
fleischesser extreme also flexitarier
kim kleiner gelatine es entweder nicht
aus tieren oder schlachter weil kein
tier wird winter native geschlachtet
kleines unterstützt nur die tierhaltung
in kleiner bin ich auch es aber auch mal
war ne arme beine von torhüter einer
leicht besser geschmeckt dass du auf
jeden fall recht was ist so schlimm wenn
man mal für ein experiment kleine
gelatine ist ich kann mal war nicht
leiden aber ich hasse euch intoleranten
vegetarier veganer so sehr dass sie in
diesem fall verteidigen
sie hat bestimmt nicht für
massentierhaltung gesorgt nur weil sie
minimale mengen an die latina gegessen
hat ihr seid so intolerant unglaublich
wenn veganismus eine religion wäre wäre
es der islam
jeder der die gesetze bricht bekommt den
kopf abgeschnitten erstmal will ich
genau so also kein veganer kanik sie
benutzt dafür veganes fleisch spricht
hofer oder so exakt ich finde die haare
richtig schön chemistry 2000 ich auch im
ernst was jedoch essen was sie will
naja schlachter müssen sich aber auch an
nichts halten kämen kleiner vegetarisch
isst kein fleisch essen wenn sie vegan
wäre dann hätte sie es nicht essen
dürfen du weißt schon für die
herstellung von gelantine tierknochen
ausgekocht werden also muss das ziel ja
auch wie bei der verwertung von fleisch
getötet werden wenn man sich veganer
nett ist man ja auch die produkte vom
tier nicht wie milch eier käse und so
weiter ich glaube dass die latina dann
noch mal etwas anderes ist maria
dietrich thier knochen sind aber kein
fleisch
game aber dafür musste ja ein tier
geschlachtet werden vegetarier veganer
essen ja nicht nur aus dem grund kein
fleisch oder tierprodukte weil sie die
massentierhaltung nicht unterstützen
wollen sonst könnten sie ja auch fleisch
von glücklichen kühen essen sondern auch
weil es ihnen zuwider ist leichenteile
zu essen oder sie die berechtigung tiere
als aus nutztiere gehalten züchten nicht
beim menschen saison beispielweise sich
den tieren gegenüber nicht überlegen
fühlen so fühlen sich doch eher die
fleischesser gegenüber anderen lebewesen
als wichtig stempeln aber die vegetarier
veganer als wichtigtuer ab milow finde
es etwas geschmacklos ein verhalten
einer person in form von charakterlos zu
bezeichnen in diesem fall jeder kann
auch selber entscheiden was er nicht
essen möchte was schon und wie viele
menge davon falls es sich beruhigt es
gibt eine bezeichnung für diese
ernährungsweise lautet flexitarier
flexit aris muss peace out anime free
ich auch was kann jeder für sich
entscheiden ja rocks womit er sie es
dann allerdings kein vegetarier ist
immer getan hat kann auch nicht sagen
ich esse kein fleisch oder eine bifi
geht immer was ist leider falsch die
latina ist vom tier und in nach wie vor
in vielen gummiartigen süßigkeit ich
glaube da verwechselt jemand vegetarier
und veganer sind leute die denken
veganer gern einer sekte vegetarismus
das meiden von nahrungsmitteln und nutzt
gegenständen die von toten tieren
stammen fleisch wurst und so weiter
gelatine käse aus natürlich im laufe
dieser durchaus kochen von kate
wegen stammt aber auch ledersofas
veganismus das meiden von
nahrungsmitteln utz gegenständen die vom
lebenden tieren stammen honig milch
milchprodukte wie käse auch dann wenn
aus mikrobielle im land hergestellt
wurde
aber auch kosmetikartikel die an tieren
getestet wurden kleiner sie ihre
entscheidungen müssen manche leute immer
missionieren gehen erlegt ähnlich gehe
nicht missionieren es war einfach meine
frage was man noch gut am fragezeichen
erkennen kann ist halt echt so ein
kleiner roboter land thieme stimme um
ein kann ein frosch ich zu 99 prozent
vegan ernähren ist nicht gleich veganer
da muss man das auch schon durchziehen
was fehlt wenn die sauren popel bei uns
dieses auch nicht blickt dingen sondern
flicken lag mal wenn du bist ein
flexitarier dem kleiner stimmt kleiner
es gibt veganer und vegetarier kannte
nein platine kommt auch von toten tieren
ist gleich vegetarier essen das nicht
leute es heißt gelatine nicht gelantine
gelatine mit gelantine ich esse auch
kennen vielleicht muss aber einmal die
woche fleisch essen ich esse bio fleisch
vom bauern nebenan weil ich sonst
mangelerscheinungen bekomme und die
ergänzungsprodukt er nicht so gut
vertragen so viel gaming ich esse kein
fleisch muss aber einmal die woche
fleisch essen märkte selbst oder sowie
gaming beim rest kann ich dir aber nur
zustimmen
mal bist du politcamp kleiner gelatine
wird aus knochen hergestellt